(man) the sharks are back.
They're looking for the best
products and Businesses
America has to offer.
The only thing
that really matters--
what is it?
Money.
If the sharks hear
a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money...
how did this idiot make his way
into the shark tank?
This is absurd.
And fight each other
for a piece of the action.
You about taught
all of America
one of the biggest mistakes
salespeople make. You blew it.
But first, the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for
or they'll walk away
with Nothing.
I'm not interested
because you don't want
to do what it takes.
Who are the sharks?
They're five self-made,
filthy rich investors
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who started a software business
in his basement
which he eventually sold
for $3.2 Billion.
Barbara Corcoran
turned a $1,000 loan
into a real estate Empire
worth hundreds of millions
in the shark-filled city
of Manhattan.
Daymond John is a fashion
and branding expert
Who grew his homemade
hats and t-shirts
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu.
Robert herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
Who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And mark cuban,
a self-made billionaire
entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the 2011 NBA Champion
Dallas Mavericks.
My name's Steve gadlin
and I live
in Evanston, illinois.
(bird chirps)
I live a really normal life.
I'm a dad. I'm a husband.
I love my family.
I work a 9-to-5 job
Building web sites.
A lot of that's
just sitting at a computer
staring at code all day.
So I think it's important
to fill your daily life
with strangeness,
with exciting things.
I'm an ideas guy.
I think of really cool,
interesting ideas.
A lot of my ideas
come to me in the bathroom,
and I think that's--
that's the voice
you really need to listen to.
So I have a product that on its
surface SEEMS really simple,
but there is
absolutely nothing like this
on the market anywhere
right now.
The first time you see it,
you're gonna roll your eyes,
you're gonna think,
"Nobody needs this,
nobody wants this."
But you think about it
for two minutes,
and you're gonna buy one.
♪♪♪
Hello, Barbara.
Hello, gentlemen.
My name is Steve gadlin
and my company is,
I want to draw a cat for you.
I'm seeking
a $10,000 investment
in exchange
for 25% of my company.
A little music, maestro?
(synthesizer playing
dance beat)
(laughs)
♪ Hey there, sharks,
my name is Steve ♪
♪ I got an offer
that you won't believe ♪
♪ for the low, low price
of just 10 grand ♪
♪ you get a quarter of
my company, you understand? ♪
♪ You go to my site,
you describe a cat ♪
♪ I draw it, I mail it,
it's as easy as that. ♪
♪ I'd invest if I were you ♪
♪ in I want to draw
a cat for you ♪
♪♪♪
♪ I'll draw you cat
that's short and fat ♪
♪ I'll draw you a cat
with a pork pie hat ♪
♪ I'll draw you a cat,
whatever the vibe ♪
♪ I draw the cat
that you describe ♪
♪♪♪
(laughter)
♪ I want to draw
a cat for you ♪
(laughing)
♪ I want to draw
a cat for you ♪
I want to draw a cat
for you.
Well done.
(Kevin) Wow.
(Steve) So I appreciate it.
Love the DANCING!
Thank you.
The turn to the side!
(mark) Oh, my god.
I saw.
That's my signature Move.
(laughs)
by now, I'm sure
you're asking yourself,
"How did this idiot make his way
into the shark tank?"
Well, let me tell you.
There is an economy
for stupid,
and I am overflowing with it.
Now with their universal appeal,
my cat Drawings
are poised to be
the next pet rock.
I charge people $9.95
for my cat Drawings.
$9.32 of that is--
is profit.
I took the liberty of drawing
some cats for each of you--
ones I thought you might order
if you came to my web site.
So, Robert, I know
you're into fast Cars.
Thank you, Steve.
Barbara, you just closed a deal
and you're looking Fabulous.
Thank you, Steve.
"Vroom vroom."
Mr. Wonderful, you are taking
your morning bath
in your tub O' Cash.
Damon, here's a fancy man
about the town,
and, mark, congratulations
on your championship.
Thank you, sir.
I have customers Who've bought
enough of these drawings
to start their own
cat drawing Gallery.
Why are people buying them?
People ask for
their dead pets.
They want to draw
about their breakup,
or sometimes I have
cats fighting an octopus
and a t-Rex on the moon.
So they try to test you for,
like, bizarro stuff, too.
Yeah. Part of it is, hey,
they know This is gonna go up
on the web site.
They want to show off
their crazy idea.
So you post
all these drawings...
every single one.
On the web site.
Yeah, an then they
share them with their friends,
and their friends come
and they purchase cat drawings
to outdo one another.
Um, and there's some people
who take this very seriously.
You draw these yourself?
I draw these myself.
I sit down at a table,
and I-I take this person's
very personal request,
uh, let it play around
in my head for about a minute,
and then I can knock one of
these out in about two minutes.
How leveragable is that?
How many can you draw in a day?
I can draw about 25 of these
in an hour,
uh, in a week I can knock out
about 1,000 of these.
But that's just with me
doing this by myself.
You know,
as this business grows,
because of the profit margin,
it starts to pay
for its own growth.
So the really nice thing about
this is I'm a web developer.
When I'm not drawing cats,
I'm building web sites.
So I don't have that overhead
that any other company
would have.
So what are your sales today?
Okay, I've sold over, uh,
1,200 of these cats.
In what period of time?
This is about a year.
Steve, what do you do with
my $10,000 if I give it to you?
What I'd first like to do
is build on my
e-Commerce platform that I have
and grow it
even further.
Uh, the other thing I wanna do
is start dabbling
into things
like greeting cards.
I love the shtick.
I love the Dancing.
Barbara was getting excited
when you turned your behind.
Not True!
So it's all very exciting,
but how does this go
from $9,000 to $100,000?
Well,
here's the leap of Faith.
Working with me on this,
you're partnering with one of
the most creative minds, period.
I strike gold in Very
unpredictable ways.
What you guys bring to that
is the business acumen
to take those ideas, we have
a fun little marriage there,
and I believe my ideas
are billion-dollar ideas.
But, Steve, the problem is
every business model
is all about Steve.
Nothing wrong with that,
but what happens
if you're walking outside
and a meteorite crushes you
into road pizza?
Steve, you've convinced me
you're a very creative guy.
But am I buying into
Steve the creative guy
and taking a leap of faith
and saying "Let's go, baby,
we'll figure out
the business tomorrow"?
or am I--are you trying
to sell me the cat business?
I'm trying to sell you
the cat business
and a partnership
with me.
Um, I-I have so many ideas
which will seem
at face Value
equally as stupid as this.
It's obvious that P.R.
Is the big push,
'cause you're not out there
spending money
to drive people
to your website, right?
Yeah, there are
no cat drawing Fairs or...
so tell me about
the publicity, uh, process.
So I'm a real hustler
for everything I do.
I tend to bring a lot
of press attention to what I do,
on a local level.
I e-mailed groupon.
I knew they had a cat mascot,
and I said, "Hey, I draw cats,
do you guys wanna do
a groupon for this?"
I got a response
the next day,
and then, uh, you know,
on black Friday we launched it,
and it was, uh, one of their
most successful--
it sold out very quickly.
Um...
and how many
did you commit to do?
Well, the nice thing
about groupon is, uh,
1,000 people said,
"I'm buying."
But only about half of them
ever actually redeemed
those groupons.
So you got to keep the money?
Exactly.
Look, very interesting.
Really small dollars.
Not investable
from my point of View.
Can I tell you something,
Kevin?
You know what
I'd love to say?
No, let him go out!
Just Let him go out!
But I want you
to go out,
and then I want you to go back
to your hotel tonight,
put your head
on your Pillow.
I promise you the last thing
That's going through your head
before you go to sleep is...
♪ I want to draw
a cat for you ♪
(sharks laugh)
♪ I want to draw
a cat for you ♪
I beg you, please,
let me do this--
I'm out.
Okay. I accept--I accept it,
and I'd like to counter,
if I could.
(laughter)
So, Steve, you've done
a phenomenal job
of free P.R.,
but does it worry you that
after all this P.R.,
that the net result
is $7,000?
I'm out.
These guys
just don't get it.
I get it.
I love your Creativity.
Thank you.
I'll give you 25 grand
for 33%. Just say "Yes."
25 grand, 33%.
Oh, man.
'cause if you don't--
if you say "No,"
that means you don't
really wanna work.
I'm interested.
I'm interested. Hold on.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm the one
that knows technology.
Don't fall
for this dirty trick.
I'm the one who gets it.
He's done it before.
I'm not gonna go
in a bidding war With cat guy.
Steve, you gotta
make a call here!
Now, mark, I would love
to partner with you on this.
I wanna ask one thing.
What's that?
Maybe 1 in 1,000 cats,
will you pitch in
and draw it for me?
Yes.
You got a deal.
Done!
what?
I love it.
You're hysterical.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
I'm very excited.
Like this?
Hit it!
(daymond) to the side!
(laughter)
Turn around. Ready?
Turn around.
That is ugly!
(Barbara) No, it's not.
It's good.
Oh! (laughs)
I love it.
Thank you very much.
Congratulations.
We're gonna do great.
Thank you very much.
We're gonna make
a lot of money.
Pfft!
(laughs)
Thank you, guys. Can't wait
to work with you.
Thanks, Steve.
All right. Thank you so much,
mark. Take care.
I don't care how Hard
you look,
you cannot find
talented people like that...
yep.
(Barbara) Mm.
That have the vision
and have the guts...
and the enthusiasm.
Like the guts to go,
"this guy's the guy."
You're gonna make a lot
of money with him.
I love it.
It's hilarious to me
that a silly little joke
I started a long time ago
has come far enough
to where mark Cuban
just became
a business partner of mine.
Holy freaking cow,
that's awesome.
Oh, my gosh.
♪♪♪
Next up is Dave Greco,
who believes he has
an education system
that can teach anyone
to be a better salesperson.
My name is Dave Greco
and my business
is the salespreneur.
And I'm seeking
a $90,000 investment
in exchange for 40% equity
in my firm.
And I'm an expert
sales professional.
I could sell anything
to anyone,
and I've always
hit my quota.
Been in the top 2% of every firm
I've ever worked for.
And I've won
every sales performance award
there is to win.
When I was 5 years old,
I would sell pencils
out of my parents' house
for 10 cents a piece
to my neighbors.
I've been selling
ever Since.
That's why I created
the salespreneur system.
I've developed a system
to get you
in front of the real Decision
maker who can make the buy,
who can say "Yes."
Now our system consists
of two critical components--
the first is missile--
a razor-sharp
step-by-Step system
which teaches you how to find,
get in front of,
and what to say
to your original buyer.
Second is roadmapp--
an INDUSTRY-specific guide
which teaches you
how to frame your pitch
to your audience
once you're inside
and in front of them.
We're successfully deployed
in several companies
and we want to sell it
through a downloadable
mobile Application.
Great salespeople
are trained, not born.
Give me a "C" Performer
with a solid work ethic,
and I promise you my system
will teach them
to close more deals
than the smartest person
in any room.
Salespreneur is the tool
which helps sales professionals
in any industry.
Dave, you're trying
to sell me the idea
that you can make anybody
into a great salesman?
That's it.
I'm here for one reason--
to close this deal.
What questions
can I answer for you?
How much have you sold?
$40,000...
dollars worth?
In the last three months.
And how many organizations?
We're in 5 organizations,
and 3 of the fortune 300.
Can you walk us through
the business models?
How do you get paid?
Right now,
me or somebody
from my team will go out
and teach the system.
Then we sell them
the actual booklets
that you see in print.
All right. You've got
three "Fortune" Accounts...
correct.
And you've only sold, between
the 3 of them, $40,000?
We've only been selling
three months.
And what's a typical sale?
Break down a sale for me.
A typical sale would be anywhere
between 10 to 20 people
in a room, where--
and so they each buy a book?
They each buy a book.
It's per seat.
(Barbara) Who's in those seats?
The sales reps.
Corporations buying
the books?
The corporations are buying
the system for their people.
What percentage increase,
on average,
am I gonna get
in increased sales
because they took your system?
At least 40%.
40%?
40%. And here--
David, if you really can
increase sales 40%,
why haven't you sold
thousands?
He's only been
in business three months!
He's only got one guy.
We're deployed
in a fortune 100--
one of the largest insurance
companies in the world.
What company?
Met life.
And met life Only bought
how many books?
We've sold 140 units
at $2.95 apiece.
Now we want to scale
the company
and take it to
a mobile application
and a video game.
Whoa, whoa, Dave.
Before we scale the company
and go into a mobile app
and... do all that,
if you were truly integrated
within met Life's program,
they have over 100,000
salespeople, don't they?
I mean...
that's the opportunity.
Why do you want to do
mobile apps?
Because--
I wanna do mobile apps
because it's more
predictive cash flow.
I can measure the lifetime
value of my customer that way.
Okay, David,
but isn't the real
opportunity of it to sell more
to the fortune 100 accounts?
There is, absolutely.
But I can't be
everywhere at once,
and I don't want
to be everywhere at once.
David, is not what
you're really selling today,
you're selling yourself?
Not at all.
I'm selling my system
and my intellectual capital.
Because what we've done is,
we've trademarked
and copy written
all of our material here.
So it's basically,
the secret sauce is right here.
And if you deploy this
and you follow it,
it's like a diet.
We have a company in Boston,
a small start-up,
that just got
their second round of funding,
and we just took their sales
from $30 to $60 million.
May I see that
secret sauce a minute?
How can you have done that
in three months?
Robert, you should partner
with me to find out.
(laughs)
This guy's a salesman.
Being a salesperson's
about being adaptive.
Do me a favor, David.
Can you sell me this pen?
Sell us this pen
right here.
Absolutely.
So, daymond,
thank you for your time.
I've got a great product
for you today,
and it's this beautiful
pen right here.
So the features of it
are it's shiny,
it's gonna fit nice
in your hand,
and people are gonna be
impressed
but the impact
that you're missing
is that this pen is gonna
help change your life,
because when you sign
your deal with me,
you're gonna be
a very wealthy man,
wealthier than you are
right now.
This pen--and this is where
everybody gets confused--
people--
sell it to me.
Sell it to me. Keep selling.
People focus on
the features and benefits.
Tell me when you're done
with the sale.
I just wanna see
if I'm impressed.
That was it?
That's it.
Well, you haven't gone
for the close yet.
The Impact--
the Impact is you
inking the deal with me.
But, David, isn't--
oh, wait, wait, wait, Stop.
Hated it. I'm out.
Good. So I'll do you a favor,
daymond. You're out.
You'll do me a favor
and talk to them.
(mark laughs)
David, look,
I-I know you can sell.
But the issue is,
today you're selling yourself.
To sell a mobile app that you're
not in front of me selling,
you've gotta have
a sense of credibility.
You've gotta have a book.
You've gotta have something.
There's gotta be something
that makes me download that app.
Well, I have to
start somewhere.
So let me tell you
what "Somewhere" Looks like.
We've got a production company
ready, willing, and able
to help us
produce this content.
I invested my own money.
I mortgaged my house
and I have
a second Lien on my house.
Who cares?
Dave, there's a huge
hunger in America
for people that can sell.
I don't--
I don't disagree that there's
a seminar business
that you could do.
You can sell you.
But I-I'm just not buying
going from you to a mobile app.
I'm out.
Give me one company
that has successfully
provided a mobile app
that increases sales.
None. I want to be
the first.
Yeah, but that's my point.
The risk is huge on that.
I don't think my $90,000
is Well invested
turning this
into a mobile app.
I'm out.
David, I'm gonna ask you
a very simple question--
I'm gonna go for the close.
If I offer you $90,000
for 40% of your company
right now,
will you say yes?
♪♪♪
Three sharks are out.
Mark and Barbara are David's
last chance to make a deal.
David, I'm gonna ask you
a very simple question--
I'm gonna go
for the close--
if I offer you $90,000
for 40% of your company
right now,
will you say yes?
Is that the only offer
on the table?
That's not what I asked.
This is a classic
mark cuban Game.
That's what he's asking for.
Why wouldn't he do the deal?
You want to sell something
or do you not?
Absolutely, but I'm here
for a reason.
And I am good enough
to get in front of you guys,
so let's at least
agree to that,
which I can teach other people
to do the same thing.
So, Barbara, I'd like to hear
what you have to say.
You know what I think?
I think you're going too fast.
I totally believe
your material is great.
I really combed through it.
But any time you go into
any kind of a mobile app,
I have learned it costs you
so much more
than you ever envisioned.
I think you should stick
with what you're doing.
It's too much too fast.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Mr. Cuban...
what do we need to do
right now to ink a deal?
Because you know
and I know this can work.
I want it to sink in on you
very, very hard...
so it just reverberates
through your whole body.
What was my last question
to you?
Would I take
the $90,000 for 40%?
You had a chance to close,
didn't you?
And instead you diverted
all your attention...
no, I wanted to hear
the room out,
which is what
the "Shark tank" is all about.
No, in your particular case,
the "Shark tank"
Is about selling.
It's about taking your business
to the next level.
You about taught
all of America
one of the biggest mistakes
salespeople make.
When they have a deal
in front of them,
you should just shut up
and take the deal...
hallelujah.
Instead of keep on selling.
And you kept on trying
to sell.
So do you like the idea?
Do you think it can work,
and would you wanna see
a net increase
of 30 to 50% in your company?
Again, what was
my question to you?
Of course I like the deal.
Of course I like
the opportunity,
which is why I offered you
a chance to close it.
The problem is,
you basically took
the whole thing for granted.
I didn't take it
for granted, not one bit.
You blew it.
You had the deal,
it was in your hand,
I was ready to close...
mark, it still is.
I would have
written you a check.
It still is, mark.
I'm not giving you
an objection
and asking for a reply.
I'm just telling you
that I'm out.
Thank you.
Apparently, you're not
the world's best salesman.
Apparently,
you're not Mr. Wonderful.
(laughter)
Touche.
(mark) Touche for that.
How many people
did you close, Dave?
I'm okay.
They learned a lesson.
That's what matters.
Thank you, guys.
♪♪♪
I think you jerked
his chain.
I would have closed
in a heartbeat.
You know, maybe--
maybe he deserved it.
When their sales ratios
are down in the toilet,
they're gonna wonder why--
"You know what?
I let one slip away."
and they're gonna
have to live with That.
♪♪♪
Last season, Rebecca rescate
made a deal
with Kevin Harrington
for her toilet training system
for cats--citikitty.
20% and $100,000?
Yes.
Okay.
(cheers)
(man) Let's see what
she's up to now.
I'm here with Rebecca,
the creator of citikitty,
and we are so excited.
We're launching
in Walgreen's today.
(Rebecca) When I launched
this company six years ago,
this was my dream
for citikitty--
to see the product
sitting on a shelf.
Since going on "Shark tank,"
the sales have gone
through the roof
and the manufacturer
is running around the clock.
We recently launched
an INFOMERCIAL spot
which now gives us
the ability
to sell product directly to
the consumer sitting at home.
Before "Shark tank,"
citikitty Had
only $100,000
in sales a year,
and now citikitty is breaking
a million this year alone.
Sales keep going up.
I just cannot believe it.
Thank you, Kevin,
and thank you, "Shark Tank."
♪♪♪
Next up is Rick Smith
with Big plans
to bring his brand of
entertainment to las vegas.
One!
Two!
Three!
(Robert) Aw, cool.
Let's get her out
of there, you guys.
Come on,
help me out.
(locks rattle)
(Robert) Oh, very nice.
Yeah.
(Rick) Ta-da!
I'm sorry I'm not as beautiful
as my LOVELY assistant Tiffany.
My name is Rick Smith, Jr.
I'm a professional magician
from Cleveland, ohio.
I'm seeking
a $1.5 million investment
for a 20% equity
in my company.
There's a huge opportunity
in the world of magic
in las vegas.
And I intend to create
an extremely entertaining,
family-friendly magic show.
Now this isn't just
your ordinary magic show.
We will be adding singers...
(upbeat drum rhythm Playing)
♪ Hey ♪
♪ ooh, yeah ♪
♪ yeah ♪
wow.
(Rick) Dancers...
(mark laughs)
A unique juggling act
like you've never seen before.
I'm dizzy.
These are a few of
the featured entertainers that,
combined with my magic
and illusions,
we will create
the next big hit on the strip.
Now over the years,
I've created unique illusions.
I've thrown playing cards
further and Harder
than anyone in the world,
earning me a spot
in the guinness book
of world records.
Hey, would you mind
helping me out for a second?
Sure.
Want you to put this gauntlet
on your left hand.
I want you to hold
your left hand out.
I want you to hold this
piece of celery right here.
Please do not move it.
Now what I'm gonna do is,
I'm gonna take
one of these playing cards,
I'm gonna throw it,
and I'm gonna try to cut
this piece of celery in half.
What?!
whoa.
Oh, come on.
Watch Closely.
Watch the celery.
There it is.
Whoa!
Oh, man!
Wow.
Hey, can you--can you
help me out for a second?
Sure.
I want you
to sit right here.
Actually, can you help me
out, too, for a second?
(Kevin) Sure.
Come on down here. I want you
to have a seat right here.
Absolutely.
I have this lighter
right here.
All I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
set your chair on fire.
Okay.
No, I'm just kidding.
If you feel anything,
just, um--
if you just feel
anything at all...
Oh, (bleep)!
what? What are--
oh! Ow!
What's wrong!
You zapped me.
I did not!
(laughter)
Give me that thing. I'm gonna
light you on fire, Buddy.
Right now. That's...
I'm sorry, I'm sorry. I didn't
mean to burn your behind.
The opportunity is right here
in front of me
to take all
I've learned and experienced
to the entertainment
capitol of the world, las vegas.
Okay, Rick,
who just burnt my ass...
sorry... (laughs)
I have a question.
Yes.
$1.5 million for 20%
of your company
or your business
or your production...
Yes.
Means that you're telling me
that you're worth
$7 1/2 million.
Let's get serious here--
why?
Actually, I'm projecting
to gross $12 million
in our first year.
I'm working with one of the top
publicists in las vegas.
We've checked out
many different venues
and we found out
that on the average seating--
between 400 and 600 seats,
selling tickets
at a price of $60,
doing two shows a day,
seven days a week...
but you haven't
done this yet.
I have not done a las vegas
production Show.
(Robert) So you--
right now, I am
currently a magician
that I travel all over
the country
doing corporate events,
trade shows.
How much did you make
last year?
Last year,
I made $200,000.
And I'm supposed to say
you're worth a million-five
because maybe in vegas
you're gonna make it?
You know how many magicians
are in vegas?
They grow them
like mushrooms there.
There's lots of magicians
in las Vegas.
Look, Riddle me this, Rick...
Yes.
Who burnt my ass...
I'm sorry.
Why don't I just take
my million five
and create Mr. Wonderful's
magic show in Vegas--
'cause I'm taking all the risk
with all the capital?
I call you up, say, "Hey, Rick,
you wanna work for me?"
and I pay you.
$300,000.
Why do I have to give you,
you know, 80%,
and I get 20, and I put up
all the money.
Isn't that what
this whole dig is about?
The guy that has the money
makes all the rules.
That's how it works.
Well, I-I...
you're an employee.
You work for me.
If I don't like your magic,
I fire you.
In fact, I burn your ass.
To get your money back
right away,
I was--I was thinking that
I'd pay you
twice your investment.
If you even make the money,
and that's
the million-dollar question.
If I make the money.
Rick, the reason
most of these shows don't work
and the reason
they're so risky
is you're not a known brand.
Nobody knows
Rick the magician.
I give you the $1.5 million,
you rent the venue,
the $1.5 million is gone.
It's gone.
The day you open,
if people don't know you,
I could go to zero.
That's how all magicians--
every magician in Las vegas...
(laughs)
No, no, seriously...
but Rick,
before they go to vegas,
they have a brand. They have
a name. People know them.
No. That's not--
that's not True.
Every magician doesn't
have a name going into it.
They all have pretty much
the same story as I do.
Why not start
in a smaller town?
I'm really up for anything,
but this is--
this is just my dream,
to be this--this performer.
And you just gave up on
the dream just like that?
"I'm up for anything." You gave
up on las vegas just like that?
No, no, no, no.
I've been working on this--
this deal right here
for over three years,
working with This publicist
who has worked
for major, major...
Yeah, but publicists just
want you to pay them.
But you pay publicists, Rick.
Yeah, you just pay
the publicist,
they'll tell you
whatever you want to hear.
But the reality is, you know
vegas is incredibly expensive.
You know to get into
a decent show room
costs a lot more than
a million and a half dollars.
Right now, the rent for--
for most of the show rooms
is between
$6,000 and $8,000 a week.
A week!
A week.
My closest friend is
Siegfried and Roy's manager.
Okay.
30 years managing them.
And he manages
other magicians,
and still Cannot get
anybody else out in vegas
because how challenging
the market is.
Now, he's talking--I'm talking
about the guy
who created magic out there.
Yeah, it's one of the best
shows ever in las vegas.
This is--
this is absurd. I'm out.
What you're proposing's
insane.
I--this isn't even
a-a horrible risk.
It's an insane risk.
I'm out.
You went for
the holy grail.
You're not quite ready
to go there.
I just think if
you would have told us
that we should invest in you,
and over some period of time,
we're gonna--we'll grow
with you,
and we'll help your career
because We're sharks
and we know how to help...
I--
and we'll give you advice.
But you asked for
a million and a half dollars.
I ain't gonna write you a check
for a million and a half dollars
for 20% so I can help
your career go.
You set your sights high,
but you set them too high.
And it's not gonna work,
so I'm out.
Rick, you missed
a fantastic opportunity.
I've never seen somebody throw
a card that fast. Incredible.
But I gotta tell you, Rick,
it takes 10 to 15 years
to become
an "Overnight success."
and you're not gonna use
my $1.5 million
to become an overnight success
with one act. I'm out.
You're such a cute kid...
(laughs)
but you're nuts.
Came in, asked for too much
too soon
with Nothing to prove
that you could actually
even attempt to pull it out.
Nobody's gonna give you
the money, and I'm out.
Well, I appreciate
your guys' time,
and I look forward to seeing
you guys in las vegas.
Thanks, Guys.
Thank you.
(Barbara) Bye-Bye.
My las vegas dreams
are not over.
I'm going to continue to look
for an investment
so we can actually
make this dream Happen.
♪♪♪
Next into the tank
is Donny Mccall,
with a product he's proud
is made in America.
Hello.
My name is Donny Mccall.
My company is invis-a-rack,
and our flagship product
is the invis-a-rack
innovative Cargo
management system.
I'm seeking $100,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in my company.
Now it's because of my wife
that I'm here today
and have created
such an incredible product.
You see, I own a construction
company in my small town,
and I use my truck both
personally and professionally.
And there are times
when I need to carry
longer material and equipment
to the job sites,
but not every day.
Well, the only solution has been
a permanent rack
that is always up
and in the way.
(chuckles) Well, my wife said
she wasn't gonna ride with me
if I had a rack on my truck
and it looked like a work truck
all the time.
Well, one day I was driving down
the BLUE Ridge parkway
and I was inspired.
Now I wasn't trying
to create anything,
so I believe the lord
handed me this idea.
(metal sliding and clinking)
In less than 30 seconds,
my truck can be a transformer.
(metal clicking)
I can carry ladders or lumber,
canoes or kayaks
safely and securely up here,
while leaving the bed open
for all my other gear.
And also
in less than 30 seconds...
(clicking)
(sliding and clanking)
I can fold it down, and now
I can take my wife shopping
or even out on a hot date.
And so I believe
that invis-a-rack has
solved the problems that I faced
and the problems that I believe
nearly every truck owner
out there faces.
Now we introduced invis-a-rack
to the market in November 2010
at the S.E.M.A. Show
in las vegas,
and we were pretty overwhelmed
by the response that we got.
Now I'm committed to making
invis-a-rack and its accessories
in the United States.
I'm one man trying to do
his best for this country.
Now... (chuckles)
I know a truck rack's
not to going to save
the U.S. Economy,
but I wanna do something
that can bring some jobs
and some hope
to my small town.
Now I wanna help my family
and investors financially,
but also my church, community,
state, and country
in any way that I can.
I believe that
my vast Life experience
has brought me to this moment.
Blessings are when preparation
meets opportunity,
and I stand before you
prepared.
Thank you.
Donny, how much
can the invis-a-rack hold?
What's the weight-beared load
testing on it?
We have put 1,500 pounds
statically on here.
Still have not crushed it yet
'cause it was on my truck,
so I didn't--I wasn't ready
to destroy my truck just yet.
(chuckles) Your wife definitely
wouldn't go for that. Yeah.
Exactly.
And will it fit
on any generic pickup truck?
It will. We actually fit
on 36 million
of the 40 million trucks
in 2-part numbers.
Including the japanese ones?
Even the japanese Ones.
Where you building these?
They come from different parts
around the country--
ohio, wisconsin, and we bring it
all back to my--my hometown
in sparta, north Carolina.
Is your hope to employ
more people in your hometown?
I hope to--I hope to employ
hundreds of people.
It seemed to me when you were
talking about the hometown
that that was very important
to you.
It is, extremely.
What's going on there?
Is something bad happening?
Well, we're just in
an economically depressed region
of north Carolina,
especially--and we--
we've had some--
We've had textiles
over the years
that have now gone away.
We've had, uh, um, an aggregate
company that has gone away.
And so we're kind of--
We're kind of stuck there.
Donny, have you had any sales?
We've got $50,000 in sales
in this first year since--
$50,000?
$50,000 since January.
And that's how many units?
It's, uh, approximately
150 Units.
Donny, you fall into the market
of enhancing...
mm-hmm.
A truck--a secondary purchase
somebody has to make.
There's a huge
distribution system
that provides for that
here in America.
Mm-hmm.
Why aren't you selling
to a distributor?
Because they want
too many points right now.
It's not something
where we can provide--
Well, hold on there right--
well, the--the first question
should be,
what's it cost to make?
About $250 inside the Box.
Okay.
(speaks indistinctly)
So, Donny, the distributors want
to pay you how much today?
What's--what's the price
they wanna buy it at?
They think it has to be
somewhere it the low $300s.
And you're making it
for $250 today?
Right.
And at what volume
do you have to get to
in order to get it to $150?
If you can get it to $150.
I don't know that we could
get to $150 in the U.S.
Um...
okay, hold on there, Donny,
for a second.
You've said before
that you wouldn't consider...
I'm not gonna consider.
I'm just saying
that we wouldn't be able to.
But Let's just--Let's just
test that for a moment.
Okay.
Let's just say for a sec
that a manufacturer in Asia
could make it for $150
in quantities of...
let's say 1,000.
Mm-hmm.
All right?
That puts you in business
right now, my friend.
You'd be in business
with the distributor
that you're not doing
any business with right now.
And yet you're saying no
to that. Why?
(inhales deeply)
because it's not a product
that needs a distributor.
We can sell direct
to the retailer,
of which there are about 10,000
that we could get to.
But how do we get to them?
For $100,000
that you're asking for today,
what would you use
the $100,000 for?
The $100,000 I would use right
now would be to create displays,
to create a display where
it has this model on a, uh,
on a system that is clamped
to it and have, you know,
the, uh, a-a billboard
or, I mean, a placard behind it.
We call those P.O.P.S.
The P.O.P., right now.
Point of purchase.
Right.
And but you don't have
any orders.
I have plenty that want
product free...
for free.
So that they can... right.
(speaks indistinctly)
So you are gonna not only go
into the manufacturing business
but you're gonna go into
the financing business
at this point, because that
means that you're gonna,
as we say in the business,
hold the paper.
Mm-hmm.
You're gonna send it
to the retailer
and hopefully
They'll pay you.
But basically, you're making it
and you're selling it.
Well, that's not what
I'm saying,
is right now,
I'm not consigning anything.
I'm not--
you're not because
you don't have any orders.
R--
(daymond) With $50,000 in sales,
what was the profit?
Nothing.
Well,
because it's a start-up.
How much debt do you have?
How much debt?
There's about $75,000
on, uh...
at $50,000 in sales,
where your price point isn't
even the accurate price point...
you don't wanna
go overseas...
well, it is an accurate
price point. It is...
you don't wanna go overseas to
bring it down to a price point
where it can happen.
I don't believe the--I don't
believe the quality can stay.
So if you can find
a quality manufacturer...
No.
Can we take we take it
overseas?
No, sir.
Why not?
I just--it's not--not what
I'm going to do with my company.
Why?
(Kevin) Right now--Donny--
because I believe in what I--
I believe in what I am.
I believe in what I'm doing
right now,
and so if I can help
in any way, I will.
But that's not a way
that I believe I wanna help.
If you don't ever get to
make it yourself as a company,
who can you help?
(inhales and exhales deeply)
I believe I can make it.
I know I can.
Donny...
yes, sir?
You can't solve the problem
We're talking about here.
One man can't do it.
I'm talking about the problem
of getting it done offshore.
There's a reason
that's happening.
And there's a reason that a lot
of the furniture Manufacturers
are coming back.
Yeah, but, you know, to say
that the quality is bad
everywhere Offshore
is wrong.
Of--of course.
And so...
I-I'm kind of stuck here.
I mean, if you had
a successful business
and were manufacturing offshore,
you'd be employing somebody.
Mm-hmm.
And as you grew,
you'd be employing more people.
Then you'd bring it here
and employ more people...
(Robert) Donny...
then you'd start more businesses
and employ more people.
If you were successful, you
would need people to do sales,
you need people
to do marketing.
You've gotta do the right thing
for the business,
number one.
Mm-hmm.
And then everything else.
If the business is healthy,
everything follows through.
I understand that, for sure.
Donny, you feel particularly
resistant and closed-minded,
and that's a very bad partner
to be in business with,
all right?
And for that reason alone,
I'm out.
Okay.
Now we're right in
the meat of the number
for racks that are
on the market.
I mean, we're not too expensive,
we're not too inexpensive.
No orders, my friend.
I understand.
But you've made it impossible
for an investor to get a return.
Doesn't matter
where it's made.
Apple computer--
second largest company on earth
after exxon--
employs 49,000 people
here in America.
But it knows it has to
make its products offshore
to be competitive and make
a profit for shareholders.
Just like you do, Donny.
Mm-hmm.
And I don't hear that,
all right?
So for me, as an investor,
I'm not interested
because you don't want
to do what it takes.
That's the problem.
I'm out.
(mouths word)
Well, I do believe
that it has the potential.
There are plenty of companies
within the automotive market
that are building
in the United States
and part of what I saw
at S.E.M.A.
Was a company that had taken
their product to an asian market
to have it constructed,
and now they are losing share
because that asian market
has now created that product
and has set up a Booth
right beside them at s.E.M.A.
And--and being able
to sell that product
right from Under them without
any integrity whatsoever that--
yeah, but, Donny, integrity's
not American or Offshore.
Integrity's integrity based on
the human being.
I mean, that's really not fair
to say about--to say that.
You could get screwed
the same way in America
as you could offshore.
I have no doubt about that
whatsoever, for sure.
Donny, you know, I believe that
there's three courses and phases
you go through in life,
and I went through
the same phase.
First, I had to make it,
then I had to master it,
and now I can matter.
And I think you're trying to do
all of it at the same time.
Okay.
And I don't think
that you're doing it...
successfully,
so I would have to
regretfully say that I'm out.
Okay.
That's three sharks out.
There's only mark and Robert
left.
Right.
Start focusing on them.
Okay.
A factory worker's son.
Oh, I know. I hear ya.
I hear ya. You're hitting
a chord with me.
I mean...
You know... (sighs)
This is
the land of opportunity.
This is--look, America's
It welcomes all.
Mm-hmm.
It's tough--it's tough
when people lose their jobs,
but it's a global economy.
I think americans can compete on
a world-class scale anywhere.
Mm-hmm.
So whether you make it here
or you make it there,
you build a successful business.
It's not about "Made in America"
Because We're all immigrants.
We would've never had
the opportunity to come here
if--if everybody thought
that way.
And--and again, I'm...
trying
not to be disrespectful...
Sure.
Because my Dad was
a factory worker.
You know, and he came here
to work in a factory
and swept floors.
Right.
For a guy who was proud
from the country to...
(voice breaking)
You know, I just remember
my Dad came here
and worked in the factory...
You know, people made fun of him
because he wasn't american,
and they called him
all kinds of names.
And it--it--it hurt him deeply.
You know, my dad passed away
last year, Donny...
oh, I'm sorry
to hear that.
(crying) And, uh, I just...
I always asked him
what was he the most proud of,
and the first factory job--
not when he made some money,
not when he got promoted--
that factory job
where he swept floors,
you know, that made him proud.
So I admire what you're doing,
but I just can't get involved
with--With something
where you're not taking care
of the business.
I-I'm sorry. I'm out.
♪♪♪
Four sharks are out.
Mark cuban is Donny's
last chance to make a deal.
You know, Donny,
there's--there's just
a couple elements here.
One, I don't agree with
where they're coming from
in terms of you have to squeeze
every dollar.
There--there's always
a give and take.
But what I--
what I see here is
a very capital-intensive
business.
Right? Just $100,000
give or take
just for
the point of Purchase.
Mm-hmm.
Another $200,000
to $250,000 plus
in order to be able to get
to another price point
to be able to appease
your customers, right?
Mm-hmm.
And that creates
a very difficult return on
investment opportunity for me.
Right.
I would love to be able
to say,
you know what?
Let's just get behind Donny
and Let's just make this
happen," right?
Mm-hmm.
But there's no amount
of capital right now
that's going to get us
to a point where, you know,
it's obvious
that you're over the hump.
Right?
Right.
And so...
un--unfortunately, I'm...
I'm out.
Okay.
All right. Great.
Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you for your time.
Thanks.
I appreciate it.
(Kevin) Thank you, Donny.
(Barbara) Thank you.
I appreciate it. Thank you.
Thanks.
Thanks a lot.
You know what? You know
what's special about this?
Good old American ingenuity
is alive and well.
The American dream
I don't disagree,
but his primary point was,
"I'm gonna make it here."
And Kevin brought up
a good point.
"If you could make it cheaper
and build the business,
would you do it?"
and he said, "no."
I wanna take care of my own.
I want people to--to have this
product and enjoy this product
knowing that the hands
of the people in this country
put it together.